I was having an incredible bone pain in my shins, similar to pain I had during chemo.
I went off the lambating as a supplement for two days and the pain stopped.
So does this mean it was a herxheimer reaction and is not concerning and should
therefore resume the supplement? I would not say that shin pain is a herxheimer reaction
just I mean maybe somebody would say that I'd say show me the metabolic pathway I mean I'm just
I'm trying to figure out in my mind reading this question what the metabolic pathway would be
now I'm not you know I've stated before I'm not a giant fan of just taking the
lambating it doesn't test well for you but I just think of the pathway it's certainly I can't
imagine a pathway that you know so by definition a herxheimer reaction is when you are
killing off things in your body so you're producing what's called an endotoxin
most commonly seen when you're killing off gram-negative bacteria because gram-negative bacteria
in the cell membrane have lipopolysaccharides which are large and stimulated immune response are
difficult for your liver phase one and phase two pathways to get rid of they circulate a lot
and you can get sick you can feel ill you can feel of the tea you can feel like flu-ish
that's because you're producing a lot of endotoxins I can't for the life of me maybe it'll come to me
but I can't for the life of me so I might think that pain in the shin would have anything to do with
that whatsoever the shins are integrated by your fourth lumbar nerve
gosh I can't hear it I I don't I would say that I could always be at levels stay off of it